о.в.
в Усті на всієї школи увагою ставляться
до героїв Радянського Союзу Учителі
переконані саме на прикладах видатних
постатей треба виховувати молоде
покоління на основі цих принципів і
створили 30 років тому музей ім Івана
Кудрі саме цієї зали розпочинається
знайомства першокласників із дорослим
світом
розпочинається цей день
уроку мужності це урок проходить у нас
музеї і ведуть його діти наш
екскурсоводи які розповідають діткам
першого класу про цей музей про людей
які віддали своє життя патріотична
виховувати молодшу зі шкільної Лави
схвалюють на світі за словами Дмитра
Табачника зараз не лише діти а й
25-річний мало знають про Другу світову
війну менших наймолодших громадян
залучити до військово-патріотичного
виховання для того щоб просто люди
пам'ятали хто відстояв Київ 41 році і
поліг під ним хто визволив Київ 43 чому
скажімо не і реалізований нациський план
розкопками вже багато років займається
українська пошукова організація Союз
народна пам'ять на думку є літра
підписана угода дасть змогу школярам
вивчати війну не через шкільні
підручники а самим доторкнутися до
історії під час археологічних досліджень
для
дослідження
найчастіше знаходять пошуку в